Whether they came from veteran actors at
the height of their career or rising stars
taken too soon, last words can leave an
impact on many. These are some of the most
heart wrenching final exchanges actors
have shared with their late co-stars.
Desi Arnaz was as big as they come throughout his
acting career, which spanned from 1940 until his
final film role in 1982's The Escape Artist.
More famously, Arnaz was recognized for being
the lead in the groundbreaking 1950s sitcom I
Love Lucy, alongside his then-wife Lucille Ball.
The pair met on the set of the film
Too Many Girls and eloped during the
movie's production. Together,
the couple filmed more than 180
episodes of I Love Lucy while going on
to make films and special appearances.
"I think if it wouldn't have been for Lucy,
I would stopped trying a long time ago
because I was always the guy that didn't fit."
Unfortunately, the world's most famous
couple of the time divorced in 1960,
and shared few exchanges until
Arnaz was on his deathbed in 1986.
The 2022 documentary Lucy and Desi revealed
many truths about the Hollywood couple,
including their final words to each other.
According to their daughter, Lucie Arnaz, she
reunited her parents to have one last conversation
on their wedding anniversary, November 30, 1986.
Realizing Arnaz’s time was limited, the former
partners spoke on the phone. Ball reportedly
exclaimed her love for her former co-star, and he
replied in kind. Arnaz passed away two days later.
Most famous for performing ridiculous daredevil
acts as a regular cast member on Jackass,
MTV reports that Ryan Dunn was known as the cast
member willing to take on stunts
even the likes of Steve-O wouldn't.
A longtime member of the troupe, Dunn was
undeniably closest with star Bam Margera,
since the pair had worked alongside each other in
the Jackass predecessor series CKY. Unfortunately,
in 2011, Dunn and his production
assistant Zachary Hartwell died in
an alcohol-involved vehicular accident
in Chester County, Pennsylvania.
Torn up about the loss of his friend, Margera
spoke about the accident with E! News a short
time later. He called Dunn his best friend, and
explained that he was still in extreme pain over
the loss five days after the tragic accident.
Sadly, the former co-star then revealed the
troubling final text message that he received from
Dunn on the night of the fateful crash. It read,
"Stopping for a beer, be there when I can."
What weighed on Margera even further was the
fact that he had been in a similar accident
with Dunn 15 years prior. He recalled that,
in 1996, Margera flipped a car several times
on the same stretch of road and Margera
considered himself lucky to have survived.
Redd Foxx was a celebrated comedian best
known for his 1970s sitcom Sanford and Son.
The prominent stand-up's influence can still
be seen in comedy today thanks to his long,
illustrious career and many catchphrases.
In 1991, the seasoned 68-year-old actor
plotted a television comeback and began
work on a new sitcom called The
Royal Family. However, he died
before the series could air under extremely
unfortunate and unforeseen circumstances.
Foxx suffered a massive heart
attack while rehearsing for
the upcoming sitcom. His co-star
and friend of over four decades,
Della Reese, was caught off guard by the genuine
health troubles, as Foxx would often fake heart
troubles while grabbing his chest and joking
that he was having a serious health scare.
​"This is the worst one I ever had, son. Oh
it's the worst one, this is the big one!"
Reese told Jet that Foxx was already doing
a bit when the heart attack struck, so she
assumed his actions were purposeful.
Sadly, Redd fell to the floor and,
unable to adhere to witnesses' requests
that he get up, he uttered his last words:
"I can't breathe."
Award-winning actor John Ritter was a star
of movies and television. In the legendary
sitcom Three's Company, Ritter played the
lead role of Jack Tripper for more than 170
episodes. Alongside a slew of other television
appearances, the actor was still at the top
of his game in the early 2000s as the dad in 8
Simple Rules... For Dating My Teenage Daughter.
Tragically, Ritter died abruptly in 2003
while filming the sitcom, much to the shock
of co-star Kaley Cuoco, who would later go
on to play Penny on The Big Bang Theory.
Remembering her on-screen father, Cuoco
spoke about her time filming 8 Simple
Rules with Ritter on the 15th anniversary of
his passing. She admitted that even though
many years have gone by since his death,
her love for the actor is still strong.
In her final moments with the sitcom veteran,
Cuoco asked Ritter how he was feeling, having
heard he was sick. In a very fatherly manner,
he sat Cuoco down and told her he loved her.
"And I was like, 'I love you, too, silly
man.' He goes, 'No, I want you to know,
I love you.' And I said, 'I love
you too.' And he goes, 'That's it!'"
The pair then embraced, and that was
the last time they would interact.
Famed actress Natasha Richardson was the
daughter of Emmy Award winner Vanessa Redgrave
and a member of England's Redgrave family
dynasty. Richardson made a name for herself
in films such as Gothic and The Handmaid's
Tale, before meeting the love of her life,
Liam Neeson, during a Broadway
production of Anna Christie in 1993.
Their relationship quickly flourished,
and they would go on to collaborate on
further projects and welcome two
children. Unfortunately, in 2009,
the actress suffered a fatal head injury
during a skiing accident in Quebec, Canada.
Years later, during an episode of 60 Minutes,
Neeson shared the harrowing final moments
he spent with his wife. Before being taken
to the hospital with a significant
blood clot, Richardson told him,
"Oh darling, I've taken a tumble in the snow."
When Neeson arrived to be beside his wife,
Richardson was no longer conscious and her
husband was forced to make a difficult decision.
He explained to 60 Minutes that he and Richardson
had promised if either was ever in a, quote,
"vegetative state," their partner would take
them off life support. Neeson honored his wife's
wish, and recalled to 60 Minutes that he informed
an unresponsive Richardson of his decision,
though he was unsure if she could hear him.
A stand-up comedy legend, Bob Saget is
best remembered for his work in television.
"Kids, I'm gonna tell you an incredible story."
He provided the narrating voice of Ted Mosby for
more than 200 How I Met Your Mother episodes,
and hosted nearly another 200 episodes of
the video clip series America's Funniest
Home Videos. Still, Saget remains most
famous for his role as Danny Tanner on
the long-running sitcom Full House,
and its sequel series Fuller House.
While the characters of Full House learned
how to become a family through eight seasons,
the performers playing the roles created
their own lifelong connections. Tragically,
Saget's January 2022 passing helped audiences
realize just how close the actors of Full House
were. Many of his co-stars spoke out about the
interactions they had with Saget late in life,
but his onscreen daughter Candice Cameron
Bure's recollection was particularly touching.
Speaking with Today, Cameron Bure recalled
that she and Saget had plans to meet up
shortly before his passing, but a delayed
flight and a small argument prevented them
from meeting. The next day, Saget sent her
a long, heartfelt message expressing the
deep affection he had for his co-star.
He rounded out the text with the words,
"I love you more for the trouble you're
giving me. If that's even possible."
Without question, Elvis Presley ranks as the
biggest rock star of his time, and is often
regarded as one of the most influential people of
the 20th century. The hip-shaking singer became an
international sensation for his groundbreaking,
best-selling music that crossed multiple genres.
Launching to stardom in the mid-1950s,
Presley dominated the charts until his
shocking death in August 1977 – although,
his influence is still felt today. During
Presley's revolutionary career, audiences all
over the world clamored to see the King of
Rock and Roll perform. His natural charisma
helped him make the transition into acting,
and he quickly emerged as one of
Hollywood's biggest movie stars.
Between 1956 and 1969, Presley starred in
31 feature films ranging from westerns to
romances that almost always included
original musical numbers. Some of
his most famous roles involved the
utopian island backdrop of Hawaii,
which is where he met co-star Irene Tsu on
the set of 1966's Paradise, Hawaiian Style.
Speaking with Fox News, Tsu recalled
that they formed a close bond on set,
sharing interests in spirituality
and martial arts. However,
it was her last interaction with The King that
resonated most for the actor. She recalled,
"He just looked at me and
said, 'Keep that light burning,
baby,' and that was it. I guess he lost
his light. Couldn't find his way home,
you know? I truly feel he just worked
himself to death. It was very tragic."
An icon of classic cinema, Humphrey Bogart
helped Hollywood become what it is today
thanks to performances in timeless films such as
Casablanca, The Maltese Falcon, and The African
Queen. In life, he was responsible for one of
the most iconic lines in cinematic history.
"Here's looking at you, kid."
However, as important as he was to the film
industry, the same attention could be given to his
longtime wife and superstar actress Lauren Bacall.
The pair met on the set of Bacall's first film,
To Have and Have Not, and despite a 25-year age
gap, they hit it off. They married soon after
and went on to co-star in several movies,
including The Big Sleep and Key Largo.
Bogart and Bacall's marriage remains
one of Hollywood's truest love stories.
The hardened Bogart reportedly shed
tears the day he wed his young bride,
and they remained happily together
until his health deteriorated.
Bogart was ill for the last few years of his life,
but he had Bacall and many celebrity friends at
his side. A longstanding rumor suggests that
Bogart's final words were, "I should never have
switched from scotch to martinis," which sounds
very on brand for the actor's witty vernacular.
However, it is better documented that Bogart
spoke last to his wife, telling Bacall,
"Goodbye, kid. Hurry back."
The actress reportedly left his
bedside to attend to their children,
but Bogart slipped into a fatal
coma before she could return.
No one can deny Sean Connery's impact
on cinema. The former James Bond actor's
monumental career spanned more than half a
century. He collected plenty of awards and
acclaim while performing in numerous
beloved films, including Highlander,
The Hunt for Red October, and
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade.
The celebrated actor retired in the
mid-2000s, turning down substantial
roles in both The Lord of the Rings and
Harry Potter franchises. Thankfully,
Connery reportedly enjoyed retirement until
his October 2020 passing at the age of 90.
Connery's legacy made a lasting impression
on many performers, including his co-star
from The Untouchables, Andy Garcia. Garcia, who
has had a more-than illustrious career himself,
wrote an article for The Hollywood Reporter
in memory of his old friend days after his
passing. He even called Connery his
inspiration for becoming an actor.
Regrettably, Garcia noted that he had
not seen his co-star and hero for many
years before Connery passed, despite an
open invitation. He wrote about the last
time they saw each other at an event for
the American Film Institute, recalling,
"We had a cocktail or two, and it
was a beautiful thing. He lived in
the Bahamas. He said, 'Come to
Nassau. We'll play some golf.'"
Garcia never did take him up on that invitation,
and he wrote that he continues to regret it.
With a personality even larger than the characters
that he portrayed on television, Leslie Jordan was
a beloved public figure until his unexpected
death in October 2022. Small in stature and
speaking with a thick Southern drawl, Jordan was
easily recognizable in his onscreen appearances.
Some of his most notable work includes
appearances in the American Horror Story
franchise, a recurring role on Boston
Legal, an Emmy Award-winning guest spot
on the NBC sitcom Will & Grace, and the show
he co-starred on at the time of his death,
Call Me Kat. In addition to his TV work,
the performer gained a significant social
media following thanks to his comedic
posts during the Covid-19 pandemic.
Jordan's passing at the age of
67 shocked his fans, friends,
and co-stars. Actor Max Greenfield,
best known for the sitcom New Girl,
shared a long friendship with Jordan after the
pair met on the set of Will & Grace in 2017.
Greenfield missed his last opportunity to
see his former co-star just days before
Jordan died. In an interview with
E! News, he explained that Jordan
attempted to visit him during a sold
out book signing. Greenfield recalled,
"He texted me during, he was like, 'I saw — I
tried to get in. I saw that you were so famous,
they wouldn't let me in. They turned
— they turned my little a-- away.'"
A pure film and music dynamo, Australian actor and
singer Olivia Newton-John had a fruitful career in
both industries. As a singer-songwriter,
she scooped up four Grammy Awards,
dished out a collection of Top 100 singles, and
landed the top entry of Billboard's Greatest of
All Time Songs of the '80s with "Physical."
Meanwhile, in Hollywood, she most memorably
starred as leading lady Sandy in the 1978 musical
sensation Grease opposite a young John Travolta.
Sadly, the superstar passed away in August 2022,
and the impact was felt worldwide. Unsurprisingly,
her former Grease castmates felt the loss
heavily, with many paying tribute to their
late co-star. However, it was her Pink
Lady cohort Didi Conn, who played beauty
school dropout Frenchie, who got to have a
heartfelt last conversation with Newton-John.
The pair had remained in contact throughout the
years, speaking regularly up to Newton-John's
final few weeks. Conn explained to
Page Six that they had their final
conversation while her friend was in
the hospital. Despite her condition,
Newton-John thoughtfully spent most of the
chat concerned about Conn, who had also been
sick. She even sent her old friend flowers the
very next day, passing on shortly thereafter.
As one fourth of the Beatles, John
Lennon is overwhelmingly recognized
as a musical sensation. For the majority of
the 1960s, Lennon and his bandmates reigned
supreme over the music charts, becoming the
most influential music group of all time.
What some fans may not realize is that The
Beatles briefly parlayed their fame into Hollywood
stardom. During the height of Beatlemania, the
legendary rock group toplined two comedy films,
A Hard Day's Night and Help!, and they almost
starred in their own version of Lord of the Rings.
Of course, The Beatles separated in 1970,
10 years before John Lennon was murdered
outside his Manhattan apartment. Bandmate
Paul McCartney has openly admitted that
he was heartbroken that he could never fix
things with his old friend, saying to Playboy,
"I do feel it was sad that we never actually
sat down and straightened our differences out."
However, McCartney confirmed that the
two were on good terms before Lennon's
passing. The pair spoke on the phone, and
they had a pleasant conversation about
their families. Paul was happy to hear
that his old friend was enjoying life,
and making plans for the next steps in his career.
Sadly, those plans would never come to fruition,
and any chance at a Beatles reunion was snuffed
out on that fateful December night in 1980.
Unmistakable as gangster Henry Hill from the film
Goodfellas, Ray Liotta nevertheless established an
accomplished career beyond mobster flicks.
Speaking with Long Island Weekly, Liotta
expressed that he tried his hardest to appear
in as wide a variety of projects as he could,
which manifested in him starring alongside the
Muppets and portraying the likes of Frank Sinatra.
So, it is unsurprising that Liotta opted to
take on a role in one of the most outrageous
and original films in recent years, becoming
the villain Syd White for the rambunctious
Cocaine Bear. Tragically, it was one of
the last projects Liotta would finish,
as he passed away in May 2022
before the film even opened.
Before Liotta wrapped up his work
on the drug-infused-bear movie,
he offered some touching words to his
friends and castmates. The film was
directed by Elizabeth Banks, who previously
shared the screen with Liotta in The Details.
Banks remembers her last interaction with the
actor before he departed for another film set
in the Dominican Republic. She told USA Today
the pair hugged, and Liotta expressed his pride
in the outrageous movie they had made. Banks also
recalled another one of their last interactions,
in which he complimented the performance of
his Cocaine Bear co-star, Alden Ehrenreich.
Known for hosting the "Weekend Update"
segment of Saturday Night Live,
comedian Norm Macdonald was taken long
before his time. Macdonald elicited
laughs with his ability to crack even the
most sarcastic comments without breaking,
and has gone down in history as one of the
greats in the eyes of many of his peers.
The folksy funnyman went on to star in
movies like Dirty Work and Dr. Dolittle,
as well as star in his own self-titled ABC
sitcom The Norm Show. Sadly, the actor hid
his terminal illness from everyone but his
closest circle and died in September 2021.
Norm Macdonald's death devastated the comedy
community. Many of his peers shared their
condolences on social media. One of his closest
friends was Bob Saget, who had performed with the
comedian many times and even directed Dirty Work.
In a statement posted to his YouTube channel, he
recalled that he could tell something was up with
Macdonald in the weeks leading up to his passing.
Saget recalled that, shortly before his passing,
Macdonald texted his old friend to ask how he was
doing. Saget sent a brief reply, and got another
text a week later. This time, it simply said,
"I love you." Saget replied in kind, and the news
of Macdonald's passing broke just days later.
Fans of romantic comedies will remember the
1987 film Moonstruck well. The MGM hit starred
singer Cher as a woman falling in love with her
fiancé's brother, played by Nicolas Cage. The
movie collected six Academy Award nominations,
winning one for Cher's leading performance
and another for supporting actress Olympia
Dukakis' performance as Cher's onscreen mother.
Both actresses would continue their
successful careers while maintaining
a friendship to the end. Dukakis became a
regular in television films and miniseries,
building a significant filmography and earning
several Emmy Award nominations along the way.
Sadly, she became severely ill and passed away
in May 2021 at the age of 89. She was quickly
honored by her former castmate. Posting to her
social media, Cher recalled how often she and
Dukakis laughed together, and how fondly
Dukakis spoke of her husband Louis Zorich.
Cher went on to reveal that she
had spoken to Dukakis while she
was in hospice. While the older actor was
struggling to hear or speak at the time,
a conversation with Cher seemed to perk her
up. Cher recalled in a tweet that she told her
old friend she loved her, and a gradually
weakening Dukakis managed to say it back.
Best known for his starring role in the first
four seasons of the musical sitcom Glee,
Cory Monteith was a Canadian actor on the rise
before he tragically died in 2013. His passing
was full of sorrow closely tied to his on-screen
romance. Monteith met his long-time girlfriend Lea
Michele on the set of Glee, where each
played the other's romantic interest.
"Break a leg."
"I love you."
Their off-screen relationship became one
of the most heartwarming stories of love
in Hollywood. Monteith's unexpected death
hit his co-stars hard but they found the
resilience to deliver a tribute episode
to the actor in the fifth season of Glee.
Michele dealt with the loss of her boyfriend
and co-star in a creative way. The actress and
singer wrote multiple songs about Monteith
and she told Seventeen that one such track,
"If You Say So," was about the final
words that they shared. As she explained,
"There are lots of different emotions
— if you could see this person again,
what are the things you would want to
say to them? It's a personal story."
In terms of what they actually said to each
other, the lyrics suggest that Monteith told
Michele he loved her, and then Michele
responded by saying she loved him even
more. According to the song, Monteith then
uttered the titular phrase, "If you say so."
For anyone who owned a television
in the '90s and early 2000s,
Steve Irwin is an unforgettable figure. Suited
up in his tan shirt and shorts, Irwin was the
premier wildlife educator and television
personality known as the Crocodile Hunter.
With a heart of gold and a deep
appreciation for all animals,
Irwin especially focused on the conservation of
Australian wildlife as a zookeeper and longtime
host of environmental documentaries. Often
sharing the screen with his wife Terri Irwin,
the pair became international celebrities
hosting a slew of zoology programs and specials.
Irwin brought zealous enthusiasm and
unadulterated passion to everything he
accomplished until September 2006, when he
died during an accident involving a stingray
while filming a new documentary. Although his
admiration for reptiles was evident from his
presentations, so was his love for his family,
especially his wife Terri and their children.
Sadly, the Crocodile Hunter had a sense his time
was short, and was considering retirement in his
final days. As Terri Irwin said on the Australian
Broadcasting Corporation's Brush With Fame,
"I remember him saying to me, 'I don't
think I am going to film anymore;
I think I am just going to
spend time with my kids.'"
The last thing Irwin said to his beloved
family was "Goodbye," as he waved to them
as they boarded a flight to Tasmania while he
remained behind to begin filming his final series.
Veteran actor Scott Wilson amassed film
and television credits dating back to 1967.
Despite earning a Golden Globe nomination for
his supporting role in the 1980 film The Ninth
Configuration, Wilson struggled to find much
notoriety in the acting game until late in life.
The aging performer finally found success
and fame when he joined the cast for the
second season of AMC's The Walking Dead
as farmer and veterinarian Hershel Greene.
Maintaining a regular role on the series for
three seasons, Wilson saw his star grow even
brighter in Hollywood and eventually landed
a main role in the Netflix series The OA.
Sadly, it was at the height of his
celebrity status that Wilson passed
away in October 2018. As the shocking
news of his death broke it was almost
simultaneously revealed that Wilson would
return for season 9 of The Walking Dead.
The season debuted the next day with a touching
tribute to the late actor. Subsequently,
his co-stars honored the late
performer by remembering him
as a warm and entertaining man.
In an interview with MovieWeb,
his Walking Dead co-star Norman Reedus recalled
his hilariously touching last visit with Wilson.
"He's sitting there next to me, and he can't
speak very well. I looked over at him and
he looked over at me, and I go 'You're such a
f---ing a--hole.' And he just starts laughing."
Reaching icon status for his contributions to
animation and puppeteering, Jim Henson was the
creative mastermind behind franchises
such as The Muppets and Sesame Street,
as well as feature-length films
like Labyrinth. The voice and
performer behind Kermit the Frog and
a collection of other characters,
Henson hand-built a production company
that made people smile all over the world.
Tragically, Henson died abruptly and unexpectedly
from a common bacterial infection in May 1990.
His death devastated the community that
he is credited with creating. However,
the Muppet man did leave some final words for his
friends and family in the form of two letters.
In them, he discusses how he does not fear
death, but instead looks forward to having
his curiosities about it satisfied, as well as
getting to greet old friends who passed on before
him. He encouraged his loved ones to care for each
other and forgive trespasses. The note goes on to
detail his wishes for his funeral, including
asking his Muppet family to sing "happy and
joyful" songs. Always the jokester, Henson's
final words are the most fitting. He wrote,
"Have a wonderful time in life, everybody;
it feels strange writing this kind of
thing while I'm still alive, but it
wouldn't be easy to do after I go."
"We will miss you, Jim Henson."
One of the more recent heartbreaks to hit
Hollywood was Chadwick Boseman's untimely
death. Recognized for portraying Black
Panther in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
Boseman was an award-winning actor who appeared
on screens as far back as the early 2000s.
His death came as a surprise to most,
as he never spoke about his illnesses
publicly before passing away in August 2020 at
the age of 43. Upon the actor's shocking death,
his friends and co-stars were quick
to fondly remember the Avengers star.
Josh Gad, who co-starred with Boseman in the 2017
legal drama Marshall, had a particularly special
remembrance for his friend. Noting that the late
actor knew how important it was to appreciate
every minute we have on earth. Gad tweeted one
of the final text messages he got from Boseman.
The message, which was largely celebrating
recent rainfall in Los Angeles, read in part,
"Inhale and exhale this moment, and thank God
for the unique beauties and wonders of this
day. We should take advantage of every moment we
can to enjoy the simplicity of God's creation."
Boseman's final messages about living
every moment fell especially heavy
considering the secrets he withheld.